throughout the debut season of 1883
isabelle may's character elsa dutton
serves as one of the show's biggest
cornerstones not only does the young
dutton ancestor quickly establish
herself as a key protagonist in the
yellowstone prequel spin-off but she
also provides the narration for the
taylor sheridan created show one of the
most intriguing qualities about elsa is
her heartiness and her independence
traits handed down from her parents
james and margaret dutton played by tim
mcgraw and faith hill throughout season
1 of 1883 elsa often finds herself in
some of the show's toughest situations
as she her family and other settlers
made their way from texas to oregon in
hopes of a new life through every
potentially disastrous or fatal
encounter the duttons pulled through as
a family unit with elsa providing
audiences a unique window in their
mental and emotional headspace looking
back it's easy to pick out several
different instances and moments from
1883 where fans were genuinely upset or
affected by what elsa was going through
however there's one scene in particular
that firmly stands out above the rest
with some viewers calling it almost
unbearable to watch the scene in
question comes in the final moments of
the show's season finale elsa is
preparing to say her final goodbyes as
her condition has become increasingly
worse what happens next is a moment that
1883 and yellowstone fans will likely
never forget a majority of the finale
episode is spent trying to get her the
medical care elsa desperately needs even
though it's clear the wound is too
severe she's not long for this world a
heartbreaking decision is made james
dutton will travel with elsa and
wherever the pair stop to rest is the
place where the dutton patriarch will
lay down roots for his family's new
homestead during elsa's final moments
james takes his daughter to an open area
and they rest by a very specific tree a
tree that yellowstone fans quickly
recognized she tells her father this is
the spot let's just sit here rest for a
bit it's a poignant moment and one
that's also extremely heartbreaking to
the point where viewers were genuinely
upset and angry with paramount for
airing it elsa's death helps set up the
backstory for how the dutton family
ranch came to settle in paradise valley
montana the location where the
present-day dutton family lives works
and schemes the untimely passing of
james eldest child is unexpected and
perhaps not the kind of finale plot
twist fans were hoping to see it feels
like a cruel misdirect having elsa
taking on such an important position as
a narrator and becoming a central figure
only to be wiped off the board by
something as tradable as an arrow wound
even by 1883 standards and yet there is
something moving and knowing that it is
elsa a character audiences spend so much
time with in season one who will be the
metaphorical foundation on which dutton
yellowstone ranch is built although it's
clear to see how elsa's death actually
served to move the plot of 1883 as well
as the saga of the dutton family forward
fans were not pleased to see the beloved
character or actress isabelle may exit
the show especially in such a tragic
manner one user tweeted since elsa died
i cancelled another expressed quote i
can't live without her posting a
petition online to request that
paramount network bring may's character
back somehow their disgust flowed over
into a second tweet which included this
observation
elsa had to die because it explains how
they end up in montana how stupid
elsewhere on twitter one fan explained
quote it's just too heartbreaking and
another said simply so many tears over
on youtube viewers were just as upset
one user commented that final scene was
heartbreaking and almost unbearable
another youtuber remarked won't be the
same without elsa i can now cancel
paramount plus the death of elsa was a
moment that not only weighed heavy on
viewers but the actors as well 1883 star
tim mcgraw told variety we literally
couldn't read the final scripts to each
other because faith hill and i were
crying so much i mean ugly boo hoo
crying i was a blubbering idiot
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
yellowstone and 1883 are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one